it's not about what I want it's about
what's fair who face what a cool
character how do they make him look like
that Christopher Nolan who is all about
making stuff absolutely real he said
this is the one thing I don't want to be
too real Tim Weber from frame store is
here on the couch with us and we're
going to be looking at some amazing
visual effects that he's worked on over
his illustrious career did you know that
in gravity in some of the shots they're
like 99 CG how much of Sandra Bullock is
real in that shot
can't be a puppet puppets can't move
like that we're gonna be looking at the
baby from Children of Men we looked at
that a few years ago and didn't really
know exactly how it was done so we're
gonna get some real answers today on top
of that you actually directed a full
short film that uses a bunch of
technology that you guys developed at
frame store that's like brand new and
I'm very excited to learn about that
well you're gonna learn about all that
more in this episode
[Music]
foreign
if you haven't seen gravity it's insane
the thing about gravity that blew my
mind was discovering like how much of it
was CGI like I always figured like oh
these were sets and you guys did stuff
in these but then I discovered that
we're effectively looking at like a 95
CGI image the body is CGI the background
CGI Sandra's face is real what I love
about this scene is her performance the
intention of her performance comes
through totally in the animation
everything she's doing what she's
thinking about is there but we had to
totally reanimate her you could do no
motion capture because her movements are
not correct for a zero gravity movement
you know yeah you know so you have to
very very subtly animate tiny tiny
little details to make it feel real and
yet totally driven by Sandra and totally
Sandra's performance
this is like an iconic shot this was
like the womb shot I think was its name
right yeah the whole set the whole
background and the whole spacesuit
that's all CG how much of Sandra Bullock
is real in that shot so when she's in
the suit it's just her face and then
once she's out of the suit it is all
except for one leg which
leg that's crazy
you tell me can you tell which leg it is
I was actually looking at the lake
because I noticed the leg closest to
camera had like some muscle flexing
going on that I could just barely see
some Shadows on so I'm gonna maybe guess
the back leg so I guess the right leg
Yeah the back leg is that because she's
she's strapped in with that leg so she
can be moved around
her body yeah well she had to have
something to ground her movement so we
had to lock her leg in exactly and I
remember there being a really complex
sort of rig that you guys developed in
order to achieve those shots can you
elaborate on that yeah we use three
different techniques that the very
simplest one was occasionally they would
just be sitting there doing something
and there would be a physical light and
it wouldn't be moving too much yeah that
worked for a very small handful of
moments yeah
then we had a system where we had car
assembly robots and we put the camera on
one car assembly robots and we had one
with a light that was the Sun and one
with a massive massive big light that
was the soft bounce like from the earth
and they would move around so that they
were moving around in very complicated
ways but then the third one which was
the most successful for the complicated
shots was to put the actor in a rig that
did some simple movement but kept them
vertical and then surround them with LED
panels so it was this quite complicated
box of lights and we could essentially
map their lighting environment onto that
so that the light from the sun the light
from the Bounce from the earth the light
from the ISS as they came closer that
would you know an image of the ISS would
get bigger it was image based Lighting
in the real world yeah it worked really
well it was very successful it gave the
actors a little bit of an idea of what
was going on around them as well they
could respond to things they could see
the other actor flying past and that
sort of thing gave him an eye line and
gave them the correct lighting so that
the faces then dropped into the CG we
weren't having to undo the lighting
design of the virtual world to fit what
we shot on set this one she is on a
fairly static rig it could rotate so a
lot of the movement is on the camera the
movement has been reversed onto the
camera she's on a single axis rotation
and the camera is spinning and moving
around yeah because in order for her to
be able to get into these poses we
couldn't yeah we couldn't turn her that
way right because she'd be upside down
and the blood would go to her head it'd
be uncomfortable she wouldn't be able to
help pose etc etc so everything has to
move around her the camera the set the
lights everything is moving but at the
same time her performance is her
performance and you know you have to let
her do her performance so we had to make
it flexible enough so all choreographed
together but flexing enough to respond
to whatever Sandra did when she's taking
out her spacesuit I feel like I just I
spotted a very sleek little hidden cut
there are a few yeah a few but yeah
she's still here watching in her
spacesuit takes off her glove and the
glove and the helmet will wipe across
her face yeah and now I feel like you
switch to a different rig in a different
moment so that she can actually be
exactly anything else yeah so up to that
point all we needed was her face and we
could shoot it in the light box which
gave us much easier complex control over
the lighting but once she's actually
taking the clothes off the light box
didn't have the space to get people in
to help the clothes and the mechanics of
it so yeah we needed to join it's a
really really Sleek little hidden cut it
took me like four watches back wait a
minute they're strategically covering
her face
whoa this is crazy
gravity what a movie it takes place in
space and that reminds me of today's
sponsor Squarespace which if you are not
familiar Squarespace is the best way to
build a website in 2023 for yourself or
your small business now Squarespace has
beautiful award-winning templates which
help you navigate the galaxy of the open
internet but that's just the beginning
Squarespace has best in-game analytics
you can better understand who's coming
to your website and how they're using it
so that you can improve it over time
they also have audio and video block
features which allow you to directly
embed video and audio onto your
Squarespace website without having to
send your customers out to some other
part of the solar system
and in addition Squarespace has
simultaneous social media posting which
allows you to make one post from your
Squarespace website and have that
automatically format and go out to a
bunch of other social media profiles
isn't that handy it's like visiting
multiple planets at once
yeah you know Jupiter has many Moons
it does
so if you're interested in jumping into
your own spaceship with Squarespace it's
not rocket science head on over to
squarespace.com Corridor crew and you'll
get 10 off your first purchase of a
website or domain remember guys
Squarespace the best way to take off
in 2023 wow
she might still be alive I can't
remember so you made a whole short film
called flight and we're about to check
out the trailer for it right now
you guys at frame store and you
specifically you made this whole short
film as sort of like a testament to the
technology that you guys could build can
you talk about any of that technology
that went into making this possible sure
I mean there's a bunch of new things we
developed to make this film possible but
the sort of the the main one that was
driving us to do it is we wanted to
create a pipeline that worked with
unreal but on big visual effects
projects so visual effect projects where
you're working at quality and at scale
which most short films made in unreal
have been done with a small team of
generalists who work very tightly
together but we wanted to set up a
pipeline that you could work with
hundreds of people thousands of people
thousands of shots kind of thing you
know that's the thing so fuse actually
stands for frame store unreal shot
engine but it's also oh wow it's also
about fusing the two pipelines together
it's too fragmented the Prototype and
it's not always Pleasant because I saw
something
was she CG for most of that or is that
just like she's hybrids this this is
Again part of the process is I took a
lot of the things we did on gravity and
made them more easy to manage easy to
work with and more affordable but what's
really cool about this is that I can't
quite tell the real looks like CG and
the CG looks like real and so it all
just feels like a cohesive world that's
the aim yeah that's great and and I
think there's a couple of things one one
is this is actually in a character's
memory so it's not supposed to be
completely photo real but it needs to
have the richness the Fidelity and that
feeling that you're talking about where
you can't tell what's real what's not
real and it just has a quality to it
that is engaging one of the big things
about this was because we were making
the whole thing in unreal made us able
to do a lot more work at the previous
stage because that work isn't going to
be thrown away so we could build up the
assets at the previous stage we could
finesse the lighting we could do all
those sort of things so when you're
looking at the previous you're looking
at a much more close to finished product
when when I'm doing animation we could
immediately get feedback on how it would
look in the finished product it might be
a very quick render that could happen in
20 minutes everything including the comp
combining the live action and the CG
render and getting immediate feedback of
how small changes are going to look
within 20 minutes instead of within
three or four days wow okay it will
reduce the wasted work massively you'll
be making better decisions earlier
you'll know that that shot is not needed
or you know it makes the whole
filmmaking process more efficient more
creatively responsive to what you want
to do and and you can avoid those sort
of situations these kind of episodes are
always a treat because anytime we have a
guest from the industry here on the show
oh we get so many good stories and so
many good details but they don't all
make it into the YouTube episodes they
do however make it into the extended
cuts on Corridor digital.com so come
join us over there it's a good time
Harry Potter and the Goblet of Fire I
remember when this movie came out
so this shot we're seeing a lot of
underwater effects here and the first
thing that comes to mind is this looks
accurately murky you know like the fall
off of light feels like what it would
actually be like underwater which I know
would be a challenging thing to get it
well it's actually and some of the
modeling of how light behaves in water
has been done and it can be put into a
render because of technology and
understanding and knowledge so we had to
just develop it by Eye I'd say a lot of
it in comp trying to work out what would
happen to the different frequencies of
light and the chromatic aberration you'd
get because of the lenses we did want to
make it feel natural and real but at the
same time you've got to see what's going
on so it was that delicate balance
but he's my friend Prabhu
it's it's one thing to have a bunch of
like CG that is doing that where you
know you have that fade off of light
into the distance but you're integrating
this with plate photography as well like
Daniel Radcliffe's not CG in a lot of
these shots but his hair is Flowing as
if it is he was filmed underwater so I
guess the the reasoning behind filming
him for real underwater even though
that's so challenging is to get that
realistic hair motion yeah I feel like
these days all the hair would just be
replaced digitally anyway absolutely
yeah but that was not an option really
yeah yeah I think that would have been
extremely hard work and also his
performance you know you get a much more
real you know that drive away is great
in certain stylized situations or when
you just got a few shots and you can
control them and carefully shoot around
it but with a sequence this long that is
all about being underwater I don't think
you could have got a performance that
felt right I think any other way would
have been tricky
[Applause]
so flowing here underwater in a blue
screen situation sounds like one of the
hardest keying situations you could deal
with technically speaking how does one
separate that flowing hair from the blue
background back onto a show I'd done
before this called Gulliver's Travels I
developed a new technique for keying
that it's sort of using various layers
in the comp and lifting off brightness
differences using sort of difference
this is why having a color in the
background that is close to your final
background helps because it means you
can lift off not as a hard cut out Edge
but you can sort of use differences
basically and use them in different ways
in different places patch it all
together because it's often it's yeah
it's not about cutting something out
it's about something slightly lightening
what's behind it slightly darkening you
know it's about the transparency and how
that affects things oftentimes I've been
surprised that the big Productions like
this it's like just you're sitting down
and basically doing Photoshop frame by
frame for thousands of frames yeah but
even these days sometimes that's what
you end up doing
it hasn't changed
he usually asks for comments for like
what movies or scenes we should look at
but are there any visual effects artists
that you would want us to bring on the
show please leave a comment down below
suggesting your ideas
foreign
Children of Men so I think we actually
took a look at this sequence like three
years ago but we didn't really know
anything about how it was made so we're
making a lot of guesses but now we can
get the answers
[Music]
can't be a puppet puppets can't move
like that probably not a newborn baby
probably didn't hire an actress who had
a due date right at the end of the film
schedule
it was one of the best moments in my
career when we were walking out of a
screening and someone was overheard
saying how did they get that actress to
give birth on camera yes
that is like the ultimate compliment it
was yeah
job success so naturally we are
suggesting that this is a CGI baby you
could be right there but
what's so special about a CGI baby
didn't we see that one dancing way back
in the day
I was like wasn't that like basically
the first meme more or less yeah but
this one looked really good and I think
that was very unique about it especially
in like at this point in time no one had
really seen a CGI baby that looked
realistic and it is a very grounded film
you know it's not a it's no nothing
fantasy here it has to feel totally
believable and not take you out in the
movie at all at this point you know that
would have killed the movie so yeah and
I think in Alfonso's Minds there were
lots of reasons for doing it this way he
wanted it to be a long continuous shot
as you know he loves them but it
immerses you in the moment the minute
there's a cut you know that this thing
isn't really happening you know because
you've impossibly jumped from here to
there and you know it makes it less real
somehow whereas you know if you as a
viewer have to move every time from one
place to another and time is continuous
and there's no hidden changes there are
some but you know not none that you're
too aware of right it makes it more real
you're if you're more immersed in the
moment so Clive Owen needed to take
something this point you need to have
something in his hand something with the
right weight and the right you know sort
of basic basic shape if his hands are
holding nothing they will move as if
they're holding nothing so you need to
put like a six pound weight in his hands
so that you have that inertia absolutely
yeah but then you have to like paint out
everything and it was slightly smaller
than the baby so mostly the baby covers
it over that just makes your life okay
back in these days everyone talk about
how CG humans would be plastic and they
were totally plastic yeah and and
there's two aspects I think one is a
lack of subsurface scattering it made
the you know skin look plastic yeah
because I definitely noticed some
subsurface scattering on the baby's ear
and the fingers as they went in front of
the lamp and the other was movement and
you know the animation is also what
makes it feel real it feels like you see
the arms being almost like bouncing off
like its legs then it does the kicking
of the arms kind of going out the firing
and the muscles the toes yeah this like
it's all very realistic a lot of
reference was watched to get to get that
right yeah an animator had to like watch
baby like in the first few seconds of
their life and like those type of
motions as opposed to like all right we
got a baby they're three days old it's
the earliest we can get they behave
differently yeah yeah so it did no it
totally had to be the first few seconds
of life I had just had well I understand
a baby my wife at this point he went
through quite the ordeal
but that was good that was useful
reference too yeah
The Dark Knight wait you worked on The
Dark Knight too
the darkening is two not the darkness
yeah
hi it's one thing to put prosthetic
makeup of like Gore on a person's face
but that's additive and the beauty of CG
is that you can make it subtractive so
you can clearly see that his face is
missing that's you can see into his
mouth into his face absolutely it's the
negative spaces that yeah make all the
difference it's like especially in his
lip there like the fact you can see that
his lips are missing beyond that lip
it's so subtle for this shot where he's
kind of hiding it and the design of this
was tricky Christopher Nolan who is all
about making stuff absolutely real he
said this is the one thing I don't want
to be too real because it's a gory
disgusting face yeah and if it's too
real it will tell you out of the movie
right
you live
you die you know obviously shooting on
set he had his real eyeball there doing
this stuff
capture that separately yeah you're
motion tracking his eye but how much of
his real eye is there are you keeping
the actual pupil and just replacing all
of the the whites of his eye around it
or is his entire eye replaced sometimes
it was entirely replaced but wherever we
could we kept the little bits that we
could but it's it's often quite little
because when your eye your eyelids are
sharp the lighting on the bit that's
there is wrong so even though there's a
bit of eyeball there you can't use it
because you know it's the eyelid is
shadowing something exactly okay how did
you get his teeth to match are they all
cgts they're all cgts even like like
earlier on when he like is actually
talking and you can clearly see the real
teeth under his real lips you're saying
those are CG teeth the whole time are
they you know like the easy thing to do
is like keep that real but then when you
actually start doing that you're like oh
but now the teeth don't look like the
other half of his teeth that are
rendered even though we did everything
we could to match them it's easier just
to have all of his teeth BCG yeah I
can't honestly remember I I think we did
keep a little bit of the teeth you're
right it's to get them to match is
tricky and also the Light will be
slightly different on the teeth where
the real lips are if the other lips you
know the FED light coming in from that
side right yeah so I think the join is
certainly not halfway we'll have taken
the join a bit but maybe the ones sort
of further down complexity of the
lighting if these things aren't right
there's a subtle difference that you
notice isn't right hey if you're a new
viewer here thanks for stopping by I
hope we can see you around in the next
video but you got to subscribe so thank
you for that Tim thank you so much for
joining us it's been a privilege to talk
to you honestly it's been great I can't
wait to see flight looks super cool
there's a trailer online you can check
it out right now I'll link in the
description down below and yeah big
shout out to you and to frame store for
the incredible work and for taking the
time to join us thank you it's been very
exciting to be here heck yeah bye
everyone